hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast outreach 101 white initiating
an outreach program is vital to your lab
future and how to do it I am Judy
O'Rourke lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by roche diagnostics lab
meters lab leaders is rochas promise to
empower laboratories and the people
within them this is accomplished by
providing clinical and strategic
insights support and solutions from the
industry's top innovators neyo lab
leaders calm the 2016 lab leaders
webinar series and through lq summits
our lab leaders live events in order to
further delve into the important topic
of strategic lab outreach lab leaders
releasing an outreach ebook to all lab
leaders members in the coming weeks
ensure you're registered on lab leaders
to receive this valuable resource we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window or
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or sharing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left this webinar has
been approved for continuing educational
credits please click on this GE button
at the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credit I would
now like to introduce today's speakers
Kelly powers they can claim and christa
campbell Kelly powers CFO was recently
named one of alabama's most powerful and
influential women by the national
diversity council 15 women from
throughout the state were presented the
award during a conference in Birmingham
nikki macclain has been employed at
huntsville hospital for over 40 years
and has been the administrative
laboratory director of the clinical
laboratory since from nineteen ninety
two the key was given to primary
old in 1993 which included developing a
point of care program for the hospital
in developing an outreach program both
of which were challenging but rewarding
pikesville hospital laboratory continues
to be successful in the competitive
laboratory environment by continually
focusing on customer service patient
safety and quality improvement Christie
Campbell is experienced in management
and supervision within the laboratory
field and if keenly focused on pointed
star testing and reference lab
operations at Huntsville Hospital
ensuring those operations driving
effectiveness of the entire hospital
organization I will now turn it over to
the Huntsville Hospital team for their
presentation thank you so much beauty we
really appreciate you joining us today
for outreach 101 today we're going to be
talking about achieving your goals by
implementing the integrated seamless and
targeted laboratory outreach program and
thank you so much for that introduction
that was great before we get started on
the program today we'd like to do a
polling question and you're going to see
the polling place can come up in a few
minutes and the question is which best
describes your organization's outreach
program first first of all outreach one
outreach that's why I'm tuned in to this
webinar or secondly we have a few
customers but we really like to grow our
outreach business or we have 50 plus
outreach customers so if you'll answer
that question I will review the
objectives with you first of all we're
going to describe how laboratory
outreach program supports the strategic
mission of the health system and I think
you're going to really enjoy it Kelly
talking about the strategic mission of
our health system we also are going to
be describing the current state of the
huntsville hospital laboratory outreach
program we will review various
considerations for building the
successful outreach program and we will
discuss the financial impact of the
outreach program we're really glad you
joined us
for this program and I'm going to turn
first of all let's just look at our
results so you can see that about half
of the audience doesn't have much of an
outreach about fifty percent does have a
few customers but certainly wants to
grow their outreach business and then
about half of them have 50 plus outreach
customers so hopefully we're going to
address lots of topics for everyone in
the audience today but please submit
your questions if you have questions
along the way next we will turn the
presentation over to Kelly Thank You
deke I actually wanted to first tell the
audience about Huntsville Hospital and
our health system we currently have nine
hospitals in our system that we own
sticks that we are affiliated with three
surgery centers and are acquiring
another surgery center currently we
serve as 16 counties in North Alabama
the southern part of Tennessee and East
Mississippi on the screen you should be
able to see pictures of some of our
hospitals we have 12,000 employees and
2200 licensed beds our main hospital
here in Huntsville is a level one trauma
center with 941 beds and in her staff
for a census of 874 every day we do
everything here it's set for burns and
transplants I thought that might give
you an idea of our health system
compared to where you are so you could
kind of compare to our outreach programs
the next slide kind of shows you where
we are as far as in the region of state
of Alabama we are at the top in North
Alabama at the top of the state the blue
counties represent our primary market
share which are nine counties and you'll
also see which ones we have facilities
in some of those we own and some of
those are affiliated with us our
secondary market we serve seven other
counties in North Alabama including
Tennessee and East Mississippi again
this is pretty much our market share our
to call 15 we're a June your end in
millions this is our total revenue net
patient revenue the first is the patient
care receipts at 900 million nine
hundred and four million our nine
patient care activity at 83 million and
our interest in income donations at 5.8
million and this kind of gives you a
total of where our money cash comes from
every year next this tells you our payer
mix and who pays us as you can see we
have a big blue cross market share at
30.2 percent blue cross have about
ninety percent of the market share in
Alabama we do have some other commercial
cigna aetna Humana some of those but
blue cross by far has most of the
employers insurance we did see an
increase in commercial we used to have
probably about five or more percent in
commercial and we had an increase
because we moved all of our 12,000
employees to a sigma allegiance contract
about a year and a half ago so that's
why our commercial is at eight point
eight you can see that Medicare makes up
the bulk of our market share so we're
very much a Medicare hospital here in
patient currently represents 61 percent
of our total revenue outpatient at 39 so
we still have a lot of impatience here
in the hospital next I wanted to share
two things about that kind of fold into
our mission which is a lot to do with
population health and the changes that
are occurring in Alabama first is
Alabama community care and that is our
new or co that regional care
organization with Medicaid we are about
to start managed care with our Medicaid
here in Alabama starting in October of
this year and one of the reasons I bring
this up is how important lab and lab
tests are to improving health care
especially if our goal is trying to
decrease expenses and keeping patients
out of the hospital and I'm not sure
about your Medicaid market but we
struggle with that here in Alabama North
Alabama is a little over four hundred
million dollars a year in expand
it's on that in Medicaid and we're
taking that on at risk to try to
decrease that and keep costs down in
Alabama the next thing I want to talk a
little bit about was the Alabama one
health record that is our health care
information exchange here in Alabama we
are currently working on our interface
to go live with that it's a state
exchange we already have several
counties who are alive with it and as I
said we will be coming up really soon
and definitely before october one of 16
so that we can have all of the data from
all of our Medicaid patients no matter
where they go in the state the reason
that also is important to lab is the
fact that we'll be able to share lab
results so if someone goes to the doctor
has a lab done / has it here we can see
those results in there the great thing
about lab and we'll talk about that is
the fact that with our huge outreach
programs we're able to see a lot of the
labs here at the hospital and exchange
that without having to do another test
very very important and one other thing
I wanted to say was I know a lot of
people on the call probably are from
smaller facilities but you can have a
great outreach program in the smaller
facilities and this will become more and
more important as we have a lot of our
insurance on a risk basis a couple of
benefits very high level without reach
is the excess capacity that you probably
already have in your lab and as you know
mainly having a busy ER like we do we
have to have the ability to add on tests
all day long not knowing what's going to
be flown in or come in through the doors
so Vicki does have capacity of course
I'm sure with her outreach business that
has decreased over time but that is a
great way to add test in there increase
your revenue without adding much cost so
that's where we get a lot of a
profitability for my outreach program is
because of that excess
capacity also that the outpatient
testing is the same quality that you get
on an impatient and I know there are
certain criteria for inpatients and a
lot of that being done on the same
machine and the same lab bills that
reputation with the position so I can
trust this data so that's a great thing
for your doctors to have the same test
on an outpatient basis that they would
get on the inpatient side it also builds
those relationship with the doctors not
only with their ability to get the
things that they need done timely but
also like I said relying on those tests
and it's done the same way with this on
the same machine same reagents you know
calibration on machine and everything so
that they get they really believe in the
results once you build those
relationships it also helps them in
their office when they have a really
good rest lab that they can depend on I
think it's very important to their
managing the patients in their office
and we're going to see that more and
more again as we do this managed care or
Co we are already doing on health homes
here in North Alabama and have really
cut Medicaid costs due to bad the next
thing is allows the institution to
manage population health and I know that
has really become a huge thing a big
buzzword in our industry and especially
here in North Alabama be we have several
tech companies that work on genetic
testing and all of that and I know we've
had a huge thing here in North Alabama
where women under the age of 30 can go
and have their the genes tested to see
if they have an increased risk of
ovarian cancer through their blood test
and that is just something that I think
in a bit individually we will be able to
use more of this genetic testing as we
try and manage population health again
it protects some of our market share and
I think that's a really big thing for us
here is to try to maintain market share
throughout North Alabama I mean you can
do that with a great lab and a great
outreach program but I'm going to turn
it over now to the experts I'm gonna
turn it over to Christy and let her give
you more about our outreach program
thank you so much Kelly thank you for
that overview of our system
that helps our audience understand a
little bit about our operations and how
we do things on a global scale and will
begin to drill down into the local
services that we provide and
particularly our outreach program here
at Huntsville Hospital we interjected
this slide it is actually a picture of
an elevated tram station that transports
patients visitors staff members and
supplies between our two main campuses
here in the Madison County area our main
hospital and then our women's and
children's facility that's about through
your three blocks up the street from us
so in the reason why we wanted to
interject this is because typically when
people think about the state of Alabama
they don't necessarily think high tech
industry but we do have a very high
focus of NASA engineers missile defense
engineers and even a more recent focus
on the biotech engineering in our area
so one of the NASA engineers that
retired from NASA a few years ago
actually came to work as a volunteer at
Huntsville Hospital was instrumental in
the design and implementation of our
elevated tram system so we just kind of
wanted to set up a framework of how you
think of North Alabama most people when
they think about Alabama they think
about excellence in football not so much
high-tech industry so I'll interject my
roll tide there and gloat for a moment
about our 16 national championships and
Counting so our engineer actually we
were discussing recently the
entertainment value of the trim as well
because if if you're looking at it it
does look very similar to the monorail
at Disney so just a little setup about
our region in the technology focus in
North Alabama we are one of the largest
hospitals in the lie in the United
States by testing volume we kind of
learned that in a published a magazine
article a few years ago and we knew we
were busy but it surprised us to some
degree that the ranking that we had
within the country but it was just
interesting to see that but I say that
to tell you
you that as Kelly was saying regardless
of your Geographic or your demographic
area outreach is possible for you our
county that our main hospital resides in
is Madison County and it's about 800
square miles and a population of about
350,000 so although we are kind of a
populated area in North Alabama our
outreach program has started to grow
outside the bounds of our County in
particular so just keep in mind that
even regardless of your Geographic and
demographic facts you can you can start
an outreach programs and be successful
in this arena of laboratory business our
lab is cata and a abd accredited and of
course we are part of that larger
huntsville hospital system that kelly
gave us an overview so just to give a
little bit about the current state of
our laboratory in the fall of 2014 we
moved our lab to a new location it was
the largest Department will move our
hospital had ever undertaken we actually
gained about 11,000 square foot of for
space in our new lab and that brought us
up to a total of about 30,000 square
feet again we are a ABT accredited and
CA p accredited and we're a fully
automated lab every department in our in
our lab has automation as a part of
their work processes we are also
supported by pre-analytical staff that
includes phlebotomy services central
processing which focuses on the the
receipt and processing of impatient
samples and our specimen of sessioning
staff which focuses on the registration
ordering and processing of samples
submitted to us by some of our clients
and our outreach business directly from
their office additionally we have client
services a call center so to say in our
main laboratory that answers incoming
phone calls provides customer services
to our inpatient as well as our
outpatient clients we have we do have a
large point of care program under the
direction of the laboratory that's also
under my oversight so I have reference
lab as well as point of care both very
challenging aspects of our lab business
but very rewarding and a benefit to our
patient population this slide indicates
that we're approaching 8000 specimens a
day through our laboratory and actually
in the last few months as the
respiratory season has come on we're
pretty consistently processing about
8380 two hundred specimens on our
busiest days of the week which are
monday through wednesday in fiscal year
2015 we booked 4.4 million billables and
our total FTEs for the lab are
approximately 208 so in our outreach
business who are the category of clients
that we serve we have basically four
different categories the first is
physician offices so we accept samples
from physician offices have some of our
phlebotomist that are employed by
huntsville hospital laboratory that work
in those physicians offices we also
serve the other hospitals Kelly
mentioned that we have a hospital system
that spreads all across North Alabama
several counties that are under our
health system umbrella and we perform
lab testing for those hospitals as well
we also serve skilled nursing facilities
and their laboratory needs which can be
very challenging particularly i would
say in the aspect of billing for those
services and Vicky will talk a little
bit about that later in the presentation
and a growing category of our outreach
client business is in the wellness
programs again Kelly did allude to that
in her section of the presentation but
what we've seen is that our Health Group
our occupational health group has
increased the services that we provide
to large large corporations in our area
and even our own employees to make sure
that they're receiving some basic live
screening basic biometric screening to
ensure that they're focusing on health
maintenance so we keep those patient
populations healthy
we serve these this client base within
our outreach call center we have a total
of seventy FTEs that includes myself one
manager two coordinators three senior
serata me Tex and a total of 45
phlebotomist we'll talk a little bit
more in depth about where those
phlebotomist work and how they serve the
patients again nine specimen of
sessioning staff and again this staff is
focused on the registering ordering and
processing of specimen submitted to us
directly from a physician's office so
that's kind of the daily operations the
support staff of for our outreach
operations includes 1.5 FTEs for
marketing and a point 5 dedicated lis
support person so really the point 5
their combined into one human being who
just has two main focuses of his job so
he's very well versed in marketing and
sales and developing those relationships
and networks with our clients but he's
also very well versed in the the EMR
aspect of the clients they will they
have their electronic medical record and
they want to submit orders to us through
that EMR and very often times they want
to see what receive all their results
back so his job is to maintain and
troubleshoot those EMRs and work with
our new clients to set up their EMR
interfaces we also have 7.8 dedicated
client services staff and amongst those
when we added up and tallied up they
have about 70 years total lab experience
so there's not many phone calls that
have to go past our client services
staff as far as assisting with ordering
and helping investigate unusual lab test
requests and where we serve this patient
population we actually have a total of
twenty-two service locations all of
those are currently with in Madison
County with the exception of one
physician's office that we serve in an
adjacent County but we have eight
patient service centers and the patient
service centers are comprised of a
waiting area
option is to help sign the patients in
get there make sure we have lab orders
available to us at the time of their
arrival and then a staff of phlebotomy
phlebotomist that actually draw the
samples provide instructions for how to
collect non blood samples and just serve
those customers our phlebotomist in
these locations are actually responsible
for registration they have to collect or
provide collection instructions for the
samples and then they have also a
customer service portion of their job
that they have to balance with all the
rest of these as you are probably aware
out patient satisfaction scores will
begin to be considered in our
reimbursement for outpatient services so
they do have to balance those those
three focuses in their job we also have
14 physician offices for which we supply
us lobotomist so the phlebotomist
actually works for us whereas a
Huntsville Hospital badge but reports to
a physician's office for their shift on
a daily basis the decision to provide an
in-office phlebotomist is generally
based on the number of patients that
that office sees in a day's time our
minimum requirement would be for
patients per hour or about 30 32
patients a day sometimes we also
consider revenue and that if they maybe
don't see that many patients a day but
the testing that they perform based on
their specialty would produce a certain
amount of revenue than we would consider
that another consideration also is if a
former lab that provided their life
services had provided a phlebotomist in
office as well okay so we'll switch from
the kind of the focus on the current
state of our outreach business to the
labs perspective on outreach you know
kind of considering why would you why
would you want to consider outreach and
I think when you're considering those
options and considering embarking on
this journey of creating an outreach
program you want to ask the question
where you want to see your lab five
years from now a real threat that exists
that out there today in the industry is
that your lab could potentially be
gobbled
up by one of the larger labs and and
then that would leave you only as a stat
lab providing stat services and maybe
some blood bank services and then
everything else is handled by an
out-of-state lab or a larger commercial
lab and i would think that most of us in
the lab industry would prefer not to see
that happen in our local lab so you
really want to consider where do I want
to see my lab in the coming coming years
and then the next question is what what
does it take to get there and to send
off some of these threats from from
outside laboratories taken over your
local business the the maintenance of
your data locally Kelly mentioned that
as far as our health information
exchange and how will be sharing data
laboratory data with those physicians
caring for our Medicare population
Medicaid population you want to keep
your data in your hands when the lab
testing goes out of state or to a large
commercial lab you lose control of that
data and the patient care certainly
could suffer and your ability to help
maintain the health of your patient
population will suffer okay so at this
point I think we have another polling
question before we talk about some of
the considerations so you're probably
question is what do you perceive is the
biggest hurdle of creating and
maintaining an outreach program so those
of you in attendance today have
certainly at least considered an
outreach program if you've not already
embarked on it so so select your aunt's
are there will give a few seconds for
those answers to come in and see what
you all perceive as the biggest hurdles
or the most challenging aspect of an
outreach program I'll kind of go ahead
and talk about where we'll be turning
next the next portion of our
presentation will be giving
consideration to the different
challenges in developing an outreach
program there are certainly internal
considerations within the lab
considerations of who will need to be
part of your team
the outside of the lab discipline so
let's see if we've got our results
coming in okay lack of support seems to
be in the lead as far as your concerns a
close second is cost okay that's an
interesting one and then the FTEs okay
so we will be addressing some of these
concerns I guess it in regards to lack
of support would that be lack of support
from your c-suite I think that would
probably be potentially what you all are
thinking and Kelly I think we'll be
coming back into the presentation
shortly to give some perspective on
maybe how to garner some support from
their speech week so thank you for
participating in that poll so as with
any journey that you decide to embark
upon it all starts with a single first
step where do we start how do we how do
we begin this journey so we'll go into
the next few slides and give our
thoughts on how to proceed that the
first thing I think would need to be
considered it 22 on your lab team it's
going to help you accomplish your goals
in developing an outreach program you
want to try to identify those visionary
lab leaders those people who are very
resourceful and creative the lab
employees that you are currently have
that like a challenge and are not
intimidated by complex issues they like
to really tear those apart and find
solutions to those also you need to make
sure that you have your technical
leaders on board those people on your
staff who who are have intimate
knowledge of your instrumentation and
its capabilities its capacity and also
the limitations these people can be
vital in throwing up the red flag when
it's time to change to an
instrumentation or a platform that can
handle the volume that you'll begin to
see with your outreach program you
basically you just want to identify your
internal champions within the laboratory
who can help you accomplish these goals
and you cannot no single person in a lab
can accomplish this alone so you do need
a team within your laboratory so once
you've identified your internal lab team
you all also want to look at
who do you need from outside the lab
what other disciplines need to be
involved in this project you would need
to consider how do i register a patient
so you need to make some friends in your
registration department um you need to
determine how that's going to be handled
with you your lab employees be doing it
or will the registration staff come
alongside and help you with that once
the registration orders have happened in
the results ready how am I going to
build for that test we certainly want to
build for the work that we're doing to
make those costs offset each other the
costs that are a concern in the life
poll that we took you want to make sure
that you're dropping a bill for that in
a timely manner and able to do that in
an appropriate way and at the
appropriate time so you want to also
make some friends in your financial
department how are we going to get these
results to the client this is this is so
important and has many challenges today
in the world of emrs and meaningful use
so there are lots of challenges and
getting results to patients in this day
and time but they're not insurmountable
you need to have confirms an IT who can
help support you and guide you to making
some of those decisions so once you've
kind of developed your internal and
other disciplinary teams you want to
decide how we're going to sell our
services who's going to market the lab
and in our experience we found that if
you can identify someone with marketing
and sales skills and the resources that
it takes to effectively establish
relationships and and close the deal so
to speak you can often teach that person
information about laboratory testing and
why we do things the way we do and why
we have all the policies and procedures
it's not always easy to take a lab
person and try to turn them into a
marketing or sales rep so that's just
some experience that we've had
personally through the years with our
outreach program and who are the clients
going to be you certainly want to look
at your your system do you have a
network of physicians offices that are
owned by the hospital those are kind of
slammed on go talk to those people first
they're likely already using your lab
services you also want to consider
maybe Prince of your department who what
positions are champions of the lab in
your organization and go talk to them if
you know ask the questions if you trust
us to do your work on your impatience
would you trust us to do your clinic
laboratory testing those are really good
places to start as far as who are your
first client is going to be you want
somebody who already likes you so
they'll come on board quickly and work
with you through some of the some of the
obstacles that you may face in the
beginning of your outreach program some
specialties that we would recommend or
suggest that you consider would be you
know multi eating multi physician
practice they're likely going to order a
lot of lab tests your ob/gyn cardiology
neurology and oncology are also good
specialties to approach in regards to
outreach clients so once you've
identified your marketing person you
know how are you going to market what
you have to offer to your local offices
and clinics in your area how are you
going to set yourself up as a good
candidate for an outreach partner you
want to have that conversation with the
prospective client and you want to focus
on what you can provide that maybe your
competitors cannot may be faced at
turnaround times would be one to one to
promote publish your list of stat
turnaround time goals and share that
with your staff or your potential
clients they want to know that they want
to know that they can get a stat result
if they need it you can also promote
yourself as a customer service focus and
certainly in the beginning maybe you
cannot speak to this later in the
beginning even maybe the lab director
will say you can contact me personally
if you have any issues with our outreach
and not getting your results or not
getting the service that you need but
you want to focus on customer service
and certainly turnaround time and then
elimination of inter laboratory
variation when you are sending both
you're impatient work and your
outpatient work to the same lab you have
very consistent report formatting you
have consistency in a relationship of
knowing that the quality is there
you're just now utilizing it or
promoting it in your outpatient setting
okay and with that I will turn over the
discussion at this point to Vicki
mcclain to give you some information
about consideration in the building
aspect okay let's talk a little bit
about billing so Billy sometimes it's a
very difficult topics for laboratories
to approach because you have to think
about okay what am I going to charge for
my services and if you're in a hospital
laboratory you may not have even
considered what your fish schedule is
all about so you're going to really have
to understand your fee schedule how see
schedule on this developed how it works
if you only have one fee schedule for
your hospital patients that's not going
to work for your outreach clients you're
going to have to have a discounted feed
schedule you do not have to discount
every single test on your feed schedule
your 2000-3000 tests but you have to
have a core group of tests that you're
going to discount because you've got to
have competitive pricing oh that you're
going to have for your outreach clients
there's a lot of concern right now about
these schedules and certainly there's a
lot of concern about what is pama going
to do to our fee schedule and if you
don't know what Pamela stands for its
protecting access to Medicare Act it was
passed in 2014 it is to reform the
clinical lab fee schedule for Medicare
so most of us know what it means by
reform they're going to take that fee
schedule and it's going to be decreased
over the next few years you may not be
aware but that fee schedule actually has
not been updated since 1984 so if you
look at about the top 25 tests on the
Medicare clinical lab fee schedule
you're going to be probably surprised it
on the reimbursement for some of those
tests and some of those tests are very
highly automated
test in our laboratories so I don't
think it's going to be a real surprise
for any of us I'll remember it's a
variable cost to our outreach programs
all we need to just keep doing what we
do go out there and sell more tasks it's
it's it's another threat but there's
always threats to every program every
single day so it's just one of those on
programs that you're going to have to
remember yes so it's probably going to
affect your revenue and move on so let's
take a little bit about the nuts and
bolts of billing in our billing we have
actually two patient types and we did
that for a reason we have the patient
and the patient is the all one that
would present to the patient service
centers they come in with their orders
are orders may be all electronic orders
that have been transmitted through the
EMR it may be still pay per rack yes
there are still lots of clients out
there still use paper wrecks all but
that's what we call the patient billing
type and then we have the specimen
billing type and that would be the arm
specimen that's picked up in the
physician office or may be picked up at
the nursing home or perhaps the
specimens that come from other hospitals
those would be the ones that we come
into our specimen accessioning area and
they would be registered there now what
those two billing types did for us is
that's how we could all develop our
financial statements for our outreach
program you're going to want to know is
this program successful are we actually
are able to measure that success so it's
very important that when you're thinking
about billing you're thinking about okay
what's our financial statement going to
look like in and let that be the driver
of some of these decisions the other
thing you have to think about is all
your veils what kind of be able to
become producing of course you're going
to be produced
in your insurance billing and that's
what you're going to have your two
different of these schedules you're
going to have your fee schedule for your
non discounted fee schedule for
primarily your impatience and maybe even
for your outpatients and then you're
going to have a discounted fee schedule
for your outreach patients you're going
to have institutional building that's
what some may refer to as client billing
and it would be our billing for your
hospital clients all billing for your
nursing homes for the ones that are part
a where it's a global payment and then
you have to think about the self-phase
billing and until recently we really did
do a very good job for self-paced it's
very difficult sometimes to deal with
self-paced when you look at the hospital
fee schedule and laboratories but what
we did is we came up with the program we
call prompt pay when the patient
presents if there are self-pay patients
then we give them a huge discount if
they pay same-day service so it's very
aggressive building patients seem to
like it it's working well for us we've
actually collaborated with registration
services to actually do the billing
piece for us we didn't really want to
have the phlebotomist have to handle the
billing part of it too they already have
to do registration insurance
verification medical necessity so we
collaborated with registration if we
have a self a patient and they go on
through registration services first pay
for those services very well for us
so remember when you're thinking about
discounting seas or outreach patients
sometimes that will make it a little bit
easier to think about your fee schedules
okay once you've thought about billing
and of course there's a lot of things
you have to think about when it comes to
billing but used to the people in your
hospital that are expert at building and
nets you see people in patient
accounting all you talk to experts to
help direct some of your billing
decisions the next big piece you really
have to think about when you're really
trying to get your outreach business off
the ground is operations what am I going
to do about operations because it's
going to affect the operations in the
laboratory it's going to affect the
medtechs that are running the test oh
it's going to affect everything you do
in your laboratory when we first started
our business it was in 1995 which has
been over 20 years ago now we we started
the business we started with some
low-hanging froze we got some positions
that were very loyal to the hospital and
there were our first clients and we knew
that we needed um to think about things
like customer service that was going to
be big we had to teach people how to
answer the telephone because when you're
doing with the physician office it's a
little difference in dealing with the
nurse up from the nursing unit we also
knew that at a time as we built the
business we certainly were going to have
to add the resources and sometimes
that's how you deal with all funding
your outreach you don't find it all up
front we started with one person in our
outreach our business and that was a
marketing person so as we would add a
client we had the excess capacity we
might have to add support personnel as
we had to maybe increase the
phlebotomist at a patient service there
but we would add it as the
operation would grow one of the big
problems that we had in operations was
switching over to automation so you can
see one of our first all issues was
archiving specimens our archiving system
used to be racks in the refrigerator we
would have those numbers are numbered
Buzzard day and then we would have to go
back and see if we could find the blood
when we had a specimen ordered in lab I
think Christy was in charge of that but
we've grown into some very sophisticated
automation sense when you think about
operations you have to think about okay
when are these specimens going to arrive
in my laboratory and they're going to
arrive primarily on second shift you're
going to start having specimen survive
about noon but most of them are going to
be on second shift so your second shift
that traditionally has not probably been
as busy as your other shifts it's going
to become very busy but they're going to
be queuing testing that's very different
from testing the impatience side because
these are going to be patients that come
from physician's office that often are
not all there cutie is not as great as
what we see in the hospital so a lot of
times that's very normal volumes you can
do automation very easy you can look at
things like auto verification works
works really well when you get these
high volumes of specimens coming through
the system and you have to remember a
lot of these are going to be specimens
that are going to be arriving after
physician office closed so you're going
to have to have a group of people that
can perform the registration very well
because you're going to want to get
these specimens in the system resulted
on that second shift particularly if
your hospital lab because what's going
to happen on third shift you're probably
going to start working on your early AMS
for your impatience at least that's
what's happened here so we cannot allow
the operations and be
specimens to go up into our third shift
because then we're going to have
problems with turnaround times on those
impatience so you really have to look at
at the resources oh when these volumes
start to grow in your second shift ok I
think Kelly it's going to take this
slide and talk a little bit about a CFOs
advice well and I think I'm going to be
breathed thanks Vickie you gave them a
lot of detail I know they probably don't
want to hear all about our system but I
want to give you a few just very
high-level thoughts for getting the
support you need based on that pole lack
of supports a big thing so the first
thing I think you need to do is come up
with your return on your investment your
ROI this is how much it's going to cost
us to do it and this is how much revenue
but also I think you need to start small
and build upon that so don't let the
cost stop you from creating the program
to eventually gain the potential of all
the additional revenue and I think
sometimes I know we do that a lot here
but you have to really look at the big
picture and that's what you've really
got to explain to the c-suite on how to
get this done the next thing is you need
a dedicated person and this was
something that i really had to be
convinced a long time ago but I believe
it is essential you have to have that
person in order to make this program
work it can't be added to someone else's
job and that person have other things to
do they really need to be dedicated to
building this with very distinct goals
on what they need to do also have a
commitment to customer service I think
customer service is very important to
making it work and then also be willing
to pay for those interfaces some of them
can be five to fifteen thousand dollars
to more but it is important because you
really want to make it be a good thing
for the doctor in their office and then
make sure two lines with your
institutions mission and strategic
direction and I don't know what hospital
out there that doesn't need additional
revenues so I think we all need that but
again I'm going to turn it back over to
Vicki to talk about some other things
that we have thanks Kelly I think that
was a good perspective from the CFO and
Kelly
exactly right start with you do need one
person who's dedicated to this project
that's probably one of the best things
we ever did we got to hire that one
marketing person and her job was to get
this program up and running and as we
got those clients and we started adding
those additional resources so I think
that was key I think collaboration was
the other with other departments within
the hospital that have expertise that we
needed I certainly didn't have the
expertise in billing but I was certainly
willing to learn and I would find those
people who were willing to teach me
because I think you have to understand
that side if you're going to be
successful you have to understand all
registration you have to understand what
what you need to turn out that bill
that's going to be successful because
like I tell our phlebotomist it doesn't
matter if we get everything right on the
front end if we can't get paid on the
back end we're all going to be out of a
job so let's just kind of look at the
financials and you can see kind of how
this works over a period of time if you
look over the last 20 years of our
program you can see by looking at this
graph that we have the non outreach
growth which has grown here over the 20
years and we also have the outreach and
you can see we have steadily grown that
outreach over the 20 years it started
out very very small in the beginning we
started out with maybe 30,000 billables
that first year so we didn't show much
of a net revenue but it keeps growing
all it takes is one or two very
satisfied clients okay and the word
starts getting around the medical staff
and that's that's what you want to
happen then if you look at efficiency
you can see that man hours per billable
if you're working in a lab a typical
hospital lab you're going to probably
have numbers that look very similar to
the way we look like in 1995 okay we had
man-hours per available with somewhere
now no point 35 obviously not in many in
many places that don't have outreach but
as you start to really push those
volumes through that laboratory then
you'll see that the man-hours per
available will and we've been this way
now for many many years it's always
consistently around point 10 that also
kind of helps you know when you need add
resources out there I think that also
speaks to the fact that we're very
automated what we did in terms of
efficiency and man-hours is we didn't
add a lot of technical all staff we
would add support staff and by that I
mean we would add people like so
bottomless processing tax the men text
in our laboratories they don't do any of
the funding work that it's done by
people we call processing text whether
it's in micro whether it's in the
automated lab whether it's and even the
blood bank we use processing texts on
the front end to take those duties off
of our med techs so they can focus only
on the testing part of the laboratories
so they maintain the instruments and
they do the testing and make sure that
the results are accurate so I think when
you look at direct costs you can see
that our direct costs have gone down
tremendously as we've grown the business
but if you look at salary costs I think
that's where you really see the fact
that we've used a lot of support
personnel over the years have really
dropped a go down our salary costs and
of course remember you've got to be
competitive with the other labs in your
marketplace so if you're trying to get
into outreach and the other labs in your
market are the corporate labs then
you're going to have to be competitive
with those labs and you're going to have
to be very efficient when it comes to
operations within your organization so
you're going to have to think outside
the box okay you just cannot omit you
can always add a medtech you have to
think about what daddies can
take from that med pack and add someone
else who can do that probably better
than the med tech so I I think if you
look at those numbers off of those
graphs you can see that but that's how
outreach can really help the
organization and if you look at our roi
over the years will it drive revenue yes
and the 15 to 20 years since we've been
doing this program we've added almost I
couldn't get it there but almost 100
million I tried to get it there but I
couldn't so it's it's worthwhile I think
the technologists that work in our
laboratory they appreciate the fact that
we do this it brings a lot of diversity
to their work and they like that we've
been able to let to add a lot of
automation to our lives that we would
have never been able to add if we had
not started an outreach program and I
think it's good for the patient for the
patients that are in the hospital and
also the patients that are at the
physician office so I'd like to thanks
to you and also remind you that there
will be another webinar that will be
coming up on the first wednesday of next
month it will be on cultivating a
culture of quality by Jennifer Dawson so
please sign up for that through lab
leaders and I think we're going to be
turning it over for questions and
answers now thank you thank you for that
informative presentation so before we
get started on the question and answer
session I'd like to remind our audience
how to submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window and we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can for
first one is if you were starting an
outreach program today what would you
can load your considerations be on
possible Medicare fee lfs changes okay
so I think that goes back well today the
Medicare clinical lab fee schedule is
good
it pays well ok so I probably starting
there right now you probably got about a
year and the fee schedule is fantastic
now yes that's probably going to make
some changes in that fee schedule and
you're going to have to all make sure
that that you understand how that's
going to affect your revenue when you do
your all return on investment but do not
allow that to stop you from starting an
outreach program because it's it's still
you're still going to be viable that fee
schedule at least in the state of
Alabama it's probably not going to be as
bad as some of the fee schedules we get
from other payers so don't let that stop
you go ahead and start your outreach
program knowing that yes that is going
to change its not going to stay the way
it's been over the last few years
although we have seen a lot of changes
even to that fee schedule over a few
years there have always been all
decreases in the last in the last few
years so hopefully that answers your
question here's the next one do you
think that tamo is going to help
strengthen commercial labs well I'm not
a fortune-teller but I think I don't
think pammal will certainly strengthen
other laboratories I think you just
remembers that Pam is out there it's
going to change your revenue stream get
in there do high quality work and don't
worry about the corporate labs out there
ok how do you charge and build the other
hospitals in your systems the tests
performed at the outlets lab and what is
your average cost per test oh wow I
guess I get to get that question too
since I do the billing um we have a
standard fee schedule for our partners
which is Hospital clients that are in
our health system it's a very great
to see schedule oh I mean we're all in
this together we're not out to make a
profit off of our partners so we look at
our direct cost it's a little bit above
direct cost just for you know the
registration or the EMR work that we
have to do but it's very very aggressive
pricing so the next questioner has four
questions for you and I'll just ask them
one at a time as over fifty percent of
your financials hang on one second we
moved over here as over fifty percent of
your financials are from Medicare and
Medicaid how will your financials
perform on HHS exchanges k plan well I
would say the first year I think we're
going to take a ten percent cuts in
Medicare right everybody is going to
take ten percent cut on whatever your
Medicare businesses is and I an outreach
I don't think our percentage is quite as
high as it is for the whole Hospital
it's a little bit different I think blue
process will be higher than out then
Medicare on outreach but you'll
definitely take a hit on your Medicare
rates that first year and the next year
and next year after that you're just
going to have to make sure that you
program that into your financials do you
use lean six sigma metrics for your lab
program yes we do I have the managers
they're very very process-oriented
that's the technical people that you
want to find that handle operations for
you they know how to take a process and
make it very lean they're very good at
finding automation that will fit into
our laboratory we try to automate as
many things as possible we try to use
all things like our verification as much
as possible so I think you have to
identify those leaders in your leg
and utilize their abilities if you're
mean point-of-care lab modular and
integrators I'll try to feel this
question this is Christy I'm not quite
sure exactly what you mean by that but
our point of care program within our
laboratory is the platforms are handheld
devices that are mobile with the patient
with the end users so we don't
particularly have any stat labs or
physician labs that we run out in
offices if that's kind of where your
question is heading but our point of
care program is focused on inpatient
units I see used ER that kind of thing
and all of our point of care devices are
handheld devices I hope I hope that
answers the question okay this person is
last question is this visual view sent
patient samples to reference labs like a
are you key question agnostic and lab
course we do I'll feel that question as
well again this is christy overall
referral testing Department and our
primary referral partner is male medical
lab in Rochester Minnesota we do however
from time to time send specimens to
these other labs that were mentioned
including as well as other labs some of
that is based on you know Mayo's testing
you maybe they don't have that sample or
don't have that test on their menu they
don't forward to those labs and it's a
it's a client that um that we work with
to provide try to provide the more
specialized testing that they request
now I will say this we are now in the
position where we need to start giving
that a more critical eye as far as you
know managing our resources will we only
have one FTE in our referral department
and then a PRN it helps along with that
on the evenings and weekends so we have
to really kind of start considering that
and in deciding if we're going to be a
little bit more aggressive as far as the
laboratories that we refer specimens to
i will say this i think this is maybe
touches on another question that was
asked in the list but what we see
because what you sometimes get into with
that is they want to do institutional
billing
and you kind of get in this mess of
who's paying the bill and who's
responsible particularly for some of the
more advanced genetics test that are not
covered by anyone's insurance but we've
seen that some of our referral labs that
we do business with they've come around
to start offering more third-party
billing where you forward the sample to
them and the patient's demographic and
information insurance information they
build the patient's insurance and if the
insurance won't cover it then they have
a plan and a process for working with
that patient to provide satisfactory
payment schedule that kind of thing
thank you give a strategy for limiting
tests that costs more to perform than
your reimbursed I think they're always
going to have a few of these I could
probably name one or two that always
make me cringe when I see them ordered I
think um that as you develop your
outreach and you're increasing your
volumes for tests that you do maybe you
have a low cost per test and then you do
get a decent reimbursement for that it
does help offset some of those costs so
so I would say if you're concerned about
that you know the particular test that i
have in minor or chromosomal microarray
some very advanced chromosomal testing
that's required and and we just we do
not get reimbursed as much as those
tests cost us but the percentage or the
volume of that test as small as opposed
to the many many BMP CMPs whatever else
we get a good reimbursement rate on out
there and we keep we can keep our costs
really low because of volume so it's
sort of an offsetting at the balance
that you have to work with there how do
you establish a relationship with a
potential client that's under a
long-term agreement with a national
reference laboratory and how do you
provide connectivity okay well that
one's a little tricky um let's say site
that uses a long-term agreement with
another lab I think all you can do is
focus on the fact that you can provide
stat turnaround times for them and
probably a level of customer service
that they may or may not be getting from
their current reference lab
you know I guess it depends on the
client that's using them you might can
sell it from a standpoint of you know we
want to keep all this local business
local we want your clinic patients to
have the same type and methodology of
results as they have when they come to
our local hospitals for service and what
was the other part of that question how
you proving a conductivity okay so very
many of these doctors offices have an
EMR in place and as Kelly mentioned we
have been willing to to you know help
cover the cost certainly our cost of
interfacing from RL is system which is
sunquest to those emrs we actually are
currently interfaced to about 30
different EMR vendors and that covers
about a hundred of our outreach offices
that we do business for so it's no small
task it's not an easy task but we do
have that dedicated lis FTE to that is a
major focus of his job every day is
developing those interfaces testing them
even gets involved in some of the
troubleshooting on the back side to make
sure that things are flowing
appropriately between those what EMR do
house we actually have to kind of touch
this on a broad broad spectrum for our
in patients in housework we use eye care
or GE centricity we're actually in the
process of considering the alternative
to that system for our lis we have some
quest and in the last couple of years we
have implemented the use of the Atlas
system for helping us manage and sort of
be a middleware between all those
different EMR vendors and our lab
systems so that was probably I hope I
touched on the answer that that question
was looking for how do you manage
critical result reporting in your
hospital a radical real felt certain
regard still reported by the medical
technologist on they they're responsible
for calling it to the nurse in charge of
a patient and for documenting
net now in the outreach setting we do
also call critical values to our
outreach clients we have kind of a
process in place that some offices have
told us do not call us with a critical
hour you know a result after or between
certain hours and and we have that
approved by our medical directors our
pathologist and then we put that request
into place but we do attempt as we have
outreach business coming at their
critical values we certainly call those
if we're not able to contact anyone
through the evening second shift in
third shift hours when those tests are
being run and we leave it for a
supervisor follow up the next morning
dew cliff pinions as climate service at
all of your draw centers and cash credit
card co-pays and does this include
phlebotomist in physician offices as
well we do not we actually um we
actually work with our registration
services who who provides for a lack of
a better word financial counseling to
the patient as far as what our programs
are that we offer people who have no
insurance or our self pay so we've
worked out a collaborative effort with
them that if we realize the patient has
no insurance and are in that self a
category we refer them to our
registration area they counsel them
offer the prompt a discount that Vicki
referred to in her portion of the
presentation and collect payment from
them that is something that was already
part of the collection of money at the
point of service was already part of the
registration services workflow in
operations so we just worked with them
collaboratively to make that as seamless
for the patients as possible we actually
don't offer it in every location in
every physician office but we have
implemented that in let's see five of
our eight patient service centers so
it's and we tried to be strategic about
where we offered that throughout the
county so it would be a you know an
opportunity for anybody in any area of
our main service geographic area to have
that opportunity to pay at the time of
service
looks like we have time for one more
question today and it is what percent of
the outreach orders are sent
electronically from opposition one
second so sorry jumps around what
percentage of the outreach orders are
sent electronically from a physician's
office and are most through an EFM our
interview oh that one's kind of a tough
question since we are kind of still in
the early phases of that of that Atlas
uses the middleware there I think you
could you speak to that i would i'd say
maybe maybe fifty percent okay i would
say right now we're probably about fifty
percent so fifty percent are
electronically sent and then we would
still get a lot of paper Rex so if
you're out there thinking that
physicians don't use paper Rex there are
still a lot of physicians that use paper
Rex at least here there are from a
workflow perspective for the staff
members though I would say you know
whatever you can do to standardize their
work and that's kind of a goal of mine
it has going to go atlases help us
accomplish some standardization and how
the orders come to our staff members I
would say you know maintain a goal of
having standard work for your support
staff because it certainly makes their
job easier when that at least comes in
with some consistency of how the tests
are orders and were ordered and where
the insurance and demographic
information are on the printed wreck or
paper rate whatever you've got out there
so that's certainly something to
consider as you're setting up your
operations you want to make it as
standard as possible inc since there are
questions we weren't able to address due
to time constraints the lab meters and
huntsville teams will work together to
answer the remaining questions and we'll
send those answers out with to all
excuse me we'll send them out with the
recording to all lab leaders members
next week i would like to once again
think we can reclaim christa campbell
and Carrie towers for their
presentations do you have any final
comments no I would just say um you know
good luck on your outreach program sir
if you need additional information or
can need a resource we're always willing
to help anybody okay I would also like
to thank our sponsor roche diagnostics
lab leaders for making today's
educational webcast possible please
visit the events page on lab leaders
calm to get more information on the next
presentation of the 2016 lab leaders
webinar series and to watch this
presentation and many more on demand and
as a reminder of lab leaders will be
releasing an outreach ebook to all lab
leaders members in the coming weeks
ensure your registered on lab leaders to
receive this valuable resource thank you